bueno pues esta mañana los separatistas
han dicho que han tenido que devolver el
fuego porque estaban siendo disparados
desde el bando ucraniano ha ocurrido en
done jets en la parte separatista en la
parte que controlan los separatistas al
sur de esa región del este de ucrania
también ha ocurrido en lugansk y ahí es
donde empiezan a enfrentarse las
versiones porque el ejército ucraniano
dice que han sido los separatistas en
lugares donde han los que han disparado
a una pequeña localidad que existe cerca
de la ciudad de lugás una localidad que
está en poder del ejército de kiev ahí
han atacado un jardín de infancia una
guardería y parece que hay dos
profesores heridos este este cruce de
versiones se produce poco después de que
el presidente vladimir putin dijese que
estaba llevándose a cabo de alguna
manera un genocidio en el este de
ucrania desde eeuu denuncian que estas
declaraciones y estas distintas
versiones que estamos escuchando en las
últimas horas respecto a ataques son y
provocaciones para volver a encender ese
conflicto bélico
xavier también moscú dice que hoy va a
responder a las propuestas de seguridad
de washington que se espera entonces en
torno a todo este tema
bueno pues parece que moscú ya tiene
lista su respuesta a las garantías de
seguridad a las propuestas sobre
garantías de seguridad que recibió de
washington hace semanas en el que dicen
que las han estado analizando
detenidamente y además nos han dicho que
las van a hacer públicas cosa que
washington cuando emitió su propuesta
pidió que se mantuviesen en privado para
moscú y difundir su respuesta oficial a
eeuu es según han especulado ha
explicado desde el gobierno ruso una
manera de contraatacar en esta lo que
ellos llaman guerra informativa
occidental que dicen que les está
colocando a ellos como los agresores
cuando en realidad desde el principio
insisten desde moscú no han tenido
ninguna intención de atacar ucrania